assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullah wa
better care to brothers and sisters we
just got here today
do you want to quickly tell you what
we're going to do we're gonna interview
the public but well first we're going to
start with a Daily Mail office I'm going
to go to the people that work there and
ask them why our sister who got killed
and stabbed 16 times are not on the
front papers but yet again once more
they have a muslim man you know and
basically as you know it's the same
story we're all terrorists exercise trip
so we was in the train and we was coming
here and asked this question to a lady
on the train yeah I said basically have
you heard of a woman that was killed a
Muslim woman who got stabbed 16 times
she said I've never heard of it I said I
said the people you read and just look
at the front page she looked I said why
do they talk about this part not that
and she said she even had ourselves each
they look it's double standards is
hypocrisy basically we just have you
heard of a woman that got killed by
being stabbed 16 times in coaches en
Colchester yeah okay wait where did you
hear which newspaper did you hear on Sky
just watching he was on Sky did it
mention that she was a Saudi woman or
she was a Muslim okay what most people
are doing is saying she was a Saudi
woman that was dressed up in Islamic
clothing now nearly got killed we know
liriko killed yeah and we condemn that
but it was oh you fool me it's just a
reason awareness that okay it's decided
course I've going somewhere and I Robin
when you said have you got a moment yeah
I didn't really also scream interviews
okay okay so we're gonna make a move now
okay so okay okay
have you have you heard of Lee Rigby
basically yeah yes he had to leave
ravine he was on the news 24/7
everywhere right why is it that when a
Muslim woman is being cured by the way
she dresses it's gone news okay briefing
best double standards in hypocrisy I'm
not in position I'm not going to make
any comment either way yeah because I
can be judged on whatever I see your
point
excuse me madam do you offer the daily
mail wish do you have any newspaper have
you heard of the woman that got killed
by again stabbed 16 times is that yes
know basically we heard of the woman
that got killed by again stabbed 16
times you have a note of it okay have
you heard of Lee Rigby
yeah we have okay this woman that got
killed by getting stabbed 16 times
well basically choose render Muslim
clothing as you know the heads boundary
yeah cuz you're a famous man
no okay I just wanna ask you why is it
about the Daily Mail talks about this
but not that common Jewish media well
for us I'm just asking basically did you
hear of a woman that got killed by being
stabbed 16 times where would she stop do
you know oh yeah you know do you know
that she was a Muslim yeah I can't talk
to you even for this boy okay how about
the records but he doesn't have you in
there
sorry man can also quick question no
I'll clear the directions have you heard
of the woman that were killed by being
stabbed 16 times really haven't heard of
Lee Rigby yeah yeah basically what is
this one that was stabbed she was a
Muslim and she goes basically cure for
the way she's dressed anything is double
stand is that this the night now because
she wasn't a pretty serviceable show
okay right so she's a Muslim shows what
happened okay so they both so she was
right for both you okay that's what I'm
saying but why wasn't it on the news or
anyway because we condemned as Muslims
what happened to Lee Rigby
but why is it that when a soldiers being
killed obviously that's a human being as
well but when a woman is being killed
it's nowhere to be found I have heard of
both law have you heard about but did
you know you know what they do papers
wrote she was a Saudi woman dressed up
in Islamic clothing they didn't say she
was a Muslim yeah we shouldn't be put in
the part we should come to give us a
mafioso for another really Specter but
why isn't it don't think this double
standard is no way to be found look what
Daily Mail votes today that is
Sanders oh I write sweet soldier
shouldn't be killing her
have you heard of the killing of Lee
Rigby yeah you've heard I yeah we have
you heard of the killing of Lee Rigby
the soldier yes I heard okay now you
don't know Lee Rigby the son loves
killed last year
now lyric we know you had yeah village
yeah good yeah have you heard of the
soldier that was killed last year you
know Lee Rigby and you haven't heard of
that okay yes I have the soldier that
but but but should oh yeah yeah yeah
okay
do you know who al Qaeda is yeah
definitely and do you know you obviously
know about the 9/11 attacks yeah
the London attacks yeah okay have you
heard of the 9/11 attacks yeah
have you heard of 9/11 I got annoying
enough you know who al-qaeda is but I
don't know him personally skating by I
thought of him yes okay have you heard
of al-qaeda yeah yeah have you heard of
them the 9/11 attacks yeah
have you heard of al-qaeda yes okay have
you heard of 9/11 yes you guys know who
al-qaeda's yeah yeah have you heard of
the 9/11 attacks yeah have you guys
heard of al-qaeda yeah okay dear
have you heard of a al Qaeda yes you
know okay dear I viewed a 9/11 attacks
yeah the 7/7 bombings have you love al
Qaeda yeah have you heard of the 9/11
attacks Yeah right
have you ever heard of al Qaeda yes I
have you under the 9/11 attacks
yes do you guys know who al Qaeda is
yeah yep have you heard of 9/11 attacks
yeah yeah the 7/7 bombings yeah yeah
do you know that in Sri Lanka Muslims
are being cured by Buddhists do you know
that a man in California drove all the
way to Detroit to blow up a mosque no
okay
you know them when Leary was killed a
week before that a man Muslim man was
butchered to death because he was on his
way to the Masjid to the mosque and the
same people that killed him were
plotting to a blogger mosque of you do
that no okay
have you heard last week a Muslim woman
was killed butchered to death again 16
times she was stabbed because of the way
she was dressed okay what does that say
about the media fast bye Jim yeah okay
also before the greeby was killed last
week before that an elderly man who was
going to the mosque was stabbed to death
which is wrong which is wrong and the
same man who did that to him granted the
plotted to blow up a mosque did you hear
about that oh it's something like that
yes something like that okay did you
hear about a man from California who
dragged all the way to Detroit to
basically blow the mosque oh yes
have you heard of that you have that's
good have you heard basically last week
a woman was killed 16 times she was
stabbed because as far as we know
because of the way she was dressed which
is wrong what is run by have you heard
of it I've heard something like that but
no it's nothing yeah okay the reason why
these things are happen is because his
media media tells lies yeah 24:11 we got
nothing to do with a terrace whose
Terrace Terrace is what yeah guys like
us I'm an African black man yeah growing
up in the same thing back in the day now
you're Muslim to gain yourself exactly
how did it feel at all wrong you feel I
was all wrong that's one say okay how
about do you know that last year when
the soldier was killed a week before
that a man that was going to the mosque
was butchered to death and the same man
who did that was panting it was put into
blah blah blah scared of that yeah you
have it okay how about a have you heard
of a man who drove from California all
the way to Detroit to blow up a mosque
again have you heard of anything like
that okay
final answer
sorry have you heard of a woman last
week she was stabbed 16 times to death
because of the way of an Islamic
clothing the way she was dressed are you
out of that ok can you--can one
explosion I don't know who hit her okay
why is it that for example when a
so-called Muslim does the killing it's
all over the media everywhere but when
Muslims are being killed
finally we condemn both for them but
nowhere nobody knows about it nobody
hears about the only thing gossipy of
double standards is a lady as far to be
honest well why did he do this
you know response basically a man you
know believe he was killed a week before
that a Muslim man was butchered to death
and basically the same man that killed
him was putting up growing up a mosque
have you heard of that
maybe I'm sure you know sure okay have
you heard of a man in California driving
all the way to Detroit to blow up
another mosque which we had 500 people
in there he was a funeral for if you
never heard of that
how about Yerevan Sri Lanka Buddhist
killing Muslims no no have you heard of
basically a man who was tortured to
death he was a Muslim and he was going
to pray and he was going home and he was
killed to death and the same people that
tried to kill him tried to blow up a
mosque have you heard of that
no have you heard of the man who
basically in California he drove all the
way to Detroit to blow up another mosque
I think so yeah maybe yeah okay
have you heard in Sri Lanka Buddhists
are killing Muslims yeah you heard you
hear on the newspaper is it okay
how about last week a woman was stabbed
16 times as police knows now it's
because of the way she was dressed
clothing is that mclogan have you heard
of that yeah yeah okay do you know when
we got killed and we before that a old
man was butchered to death and yeah and
the man who killed him was planting the
coin to blow up a mosque Avira that oh I
did hear something like that actually
where did you hear the social media or
the news media social media social makes
people you know say share story was like
I read up on this stuff others you know
like definitely had especially with that
as well like it was a base of like it
wasn't just a madman yeah it was the
fact that they put Muslim and stuff arts
mission of front pages why did it like
that I don't know that I generally
believe they're trying to breed hatred
Salaam aleikum wa rahmatullah wa
barakatu brothers and sisters in Islam
in sha allah all of you and the best of
husband iman and you're all doing fine
so as you guys saw throughout the video
we came out today and we dedicated this
whole day to our sister nun who was
actually murdered you know like last
week she was stabbed 16 times brutally
so first we actually went to the Daily
Mail and we approached some of the
journalists and some of the workers of
the Daily Mail who were actually
responsible who are actually responsible
behind some of the things that the Daily
Mail published and we approached them
and we asked them look on the front page
of The Daily Mail the Sheikh Mohammed al
Arif e linking a man that doesn't even
speak English to people in Britain going
and flying jihad in Syria okay you've
mentioned that but why is there no
mention of our sister that was stabbed
16 times in the UK this is UK news it's
not like she was stabbed all the way in
Pakistan she would stabbed in the UK and
you didn't even you know broadcast it on
the news but instead you wanted to
broadcast a Saudi person a Saudi scholar
who is from Saudi Arabia who is famous
in the Middle East he doesn't have much
significance in the UK you wanted to
broadcast that instead now what we have
come across from this whole day of
asking people and speaking to speaking
to the normal public as well we've come
across that nowadays the media has a sin
agenda the me if the media sees
something which is making the Muslims
look bad
they're going to push that forward and
they're going to happily put that on the
front page and one of the people who
actually works with the Daily Mail or
what actually works in the media he
actually told us today that if it sells
it's going to go on the front page so
what negativity in regards to the
Muslims it sells right this is why we're
always on the front line in regards our
bad way so what we came out and done is
we are certain people look have you
heard of the killing of Lee Rigby yes
they've heard of that now of course we
don't agree with these sort of killings
we're just doing a little survey they've
heard of that they've heard of al-qaeda
they've heard of all of these bad things
but when the Muslims on the low
and when the Muslims are getting killed
hardly anyone's heard of it when we
asked them about the killings in Sri
Lanka no one's heard of it when we asked
them about our sister who got murdered
recently hardly anyone's heard of it
like what is Moses said it all you know
I don't need to really talk much the
interviews talk with ourselves it's
clear what they waste on about the
hypocrisy double standards people know
more about the Muslim killing then when
a Muslim is being killed that's all done
that's all play I want to reach out to
us Muslims okay the people know that
already we on our first video we
specifically asked certain YouTube
sisters and brothers to make a video we
wanted this video to be done because we
all have a platform we all have
subscribers and people that watch our
videos we want to use this to reach to
the people and show them the apocrypha
of the media right now almost I'm not
pointing fingers that no one may other
words all the provinces were doing their
work brother from true true story a si
Adam Sally he made a video may Allah
reward you you know he made a video but
what you need to understand is this my
brothers sisters we asked you to do a
video not for us not for anyone for the
sake of Allah for your sister that's
been killed she is dead
this is what we're asking you to do a
video all due respect we saw some
sisters that left comments this post
mashallah but my sister's a video has a
bigger impact please forgive me this
close to anyone look it isn't a brother
Fozzy to you make a lot of prank videos
all this kind of stuff good on you carry
on you know there's some things I don't
agree with but why don't you make a
video if you've got time to make pranks
why do you have time to make a video for
your sister that's dead same goes with
the sisters you know each other
youtubers but you have you have time to
talk about foundation which lipstick to
use etc etc but you do not have time for
your sister that's being cute for God's
sake we're not asking you for us we
don't need your public publicity we
don't need nothing from you sister
always sign saying is you have your
subscribers for the sake of Allah make a
video and let people hear about this it
is really sad I'm showing out to people
that are subscribing to these to that to
our sister the hijab youtubers please
is ask them to make a video that's all I
want from you
we've done the public view there one is
clear what they're thinking and what's
the perception they don't agree with
that one talk calling out to us Muslims
please
pork splash I'm going to say that put
pressure on these youtubers and tell
them to make videos because our sister
is dead she is not here anymore
make dance for her and please make
videos we're gonna put the links below
tweet them message them and if they
don't like inshallah they do if they
don't I just say sisters and brothers
vows YouTube what is in there that's
that doesn't want to do it question your
intentions masha'Allah brother Ali's
addressed the topic you know in regards
to some of the sisters and some of the
brothers you know making videos I just
want to address it from a different
perspective you guys have a nice
following mashallah we have good
followings as well now some of our
audiences are different they actually
hurt me bro you know I watch your video
you know and we actually call that to
some of the sisters yeah it disturbed me
when I went on some of the posts
mashallah some of them have done
beautiful posts in support of the system
but it disturbed me that after those
posts these videos on makeup there's
videos and other things my sisters these
are worldly things that's fine but your
sister has died now if you don't want to
do your full capacity and support her in
that way don't be surprised when you're
walking down the street dressed in the
hijab and you get stabbed and are you
going to do the video then places we're
not trying to point out you for the sake
of Allah to me it's something you know
what you're actually doing it for your
own safety as well yeah because we are
all Muslims and we all want you guys to
be safe so thank you very much and I
hope you share the videos get in contact
with youtubers assalamualaikum
warahmatullah wabarakatuh
you